and also I made a promise that I would
only talk to you
that when I was ready to talk about it
I would only talk to you so I'm not I
felt like you know what I don't have to
explain to you or to anybody else why I
became a Muslim yeah and God so that's
what I was trying to avoid I find more
prejudice by wearing the hijab than a
but actually becoming Muslim you know
and I so consequently I love wearing it
you know I feel naked a very good advice
which from you know someone whose name
I'm I promise not to mention but a
prominent musician who also became a
Muslim gave everything for Father's Day
and he loved it and he said that he
would like to start to read the Quran
but I keep saying to people no don't
read it
listen to this that's why I feel like me
are reverting that's exactly can see
completely not only through it you can
see there of course you can because of
what's happened in our own church the
scandals beautiful recitations where
someone is reciting it in the Arabic and
then someone speaks the meaning of the
paragraph in English I feel so
passionately about Islam and and and
passionately by defending it against
stigma it was a good job there very hair
there trying to conform and [ __ ] to
Western men's idea of beauty so I keep
bangle if you don't like your job and
shave your hair because it's the same
thing in this country now there are many
different religions but after
Catholicism that the strongest and most
fastest growing religion in those
countries Islam is Islam er it study
don't ya uncommon things and I left
Islam laughs for some reason probably
because I have prejudice you know and
then what happened was I know the Islam
is a way of thinking about God it's
exactly what you just said somebody who
believes that nothing in this world
should be worshipped more than if God is
so intelligent so you know it's
mind-blowing I can't even find words
it's mind-blowing
I listen to that I'm more mindful well
that's exactly why Islam is so dangerous
in inverted commas to the welcome to the
world that worships money because as we
said earlier on at the beginning of this
interview desire is the truth that has
the truths I said a MOLLE come and buy
now you know what that means is they're
greeting a peace peace be unto you
and that's the same greeting I greet you
with and my next guest coming up I'm
gonna be greeting the legendary Sinead
O'Connor why she chose the way of peace
peace acquired by submission to the
crater alone that's that beautiful way
of life that she chose and everybody out
there went in a frenzy when all she did
was choose to connect her heart with the
creator of the heart the creator of the
heavens on earth
let's find out why she chose to fulfill
the purpose of what she was created for
and how you can - here with our next
guest Sinead O'Connor ah today's show
they come sister Sinead how are you I'm
good I can't see you though okay we're
gonna set it up long feet long thing in
the planning in the making we finally
made it happen
absolutely sorry hum did it love really
good hum did it LA I'm very thankful
thankful that you've found the time I
know you're very busy in there too so
let's start off by asking you you know
we're creatures of imitation but you
seem to be imitating one of the best of
creation Mary the mother of Jesus
because any picture that's out there
that they have resembling her she's
wearing what you're wearing called a
hijab okay it's funny because my
favorite coloreds where is the navy blue
as well it's fun that's funny you should
say that because from the day of my
birth I am associated with Mary by my
grandparents because in Ireland to eight
that December is what to call the Feast
of the Immaculate Conception and it's
what we we call that a big marry day so
all my life it's funny you picked up on
that all in my life every year on my
birthday my mother and my grandmother
look at me this beautiful picture of
Mary the mother of Jesus you know not in
my previous culture we would have
pictures and images of Jesus or Mary or
whatever you know so yeah that's funny
you picked that up because all my life
I've had a huge bond with the mother of
Jesus really about a huge boner I used
to go to Newark all the time yeah I
mentioned that because you know at the
Dean show we try to bridge those gaps of
misunderstanding the misconceptions and
that's one of the misconceptions you
know and meant one of the things that
people don't know is that you can't be a
Muslim unless you love Jesus as one of
the mightiest messenger and his Blessed
Mother there's a whole chapter named
after her in the Quran exactly exactly I
love that and that's why I like that you
know I get to keep my guys you know you
know and I like that for example
stay still which I which is associated
with Jesus I also have a rainy
associated with Judaism I'm a theology
student this is how I ended up at Islam
so I've gone from studying all the
different religions so I got my my
Hebrew one and then I look what I liked
about becoming Muslim I didn't have to
lose any of these things these are the
stepping stones are brought into Islam
so I'm proud of them to know and even I
have tattoos and things but they're all
scriptures and again those are the
stepping stones that led me to Islam so
and I love that I find them again in an
in Islam but much wider much more
present and I love that you all have a
chapter Islam as a chapter dedicated to
the mother because my culture she gets a
very small mansion well there's no
there's no introduction needed
we're with Sinead O'Connor one of the
legends out there you you actually made
us statements and it's really profound
but first before that I want to say that
you you purposely didn't want to do any
interviews because you didn't want
people questioning your sincerity in
this decision of becoming a Muslim no it
was more because I felt that I didn't
want to have to a was it was a private
derision
yeah um B I didn't want to I didn't
enjoy privately having to justify it to
people yeah there's so much there's so
much stigma you know and I felt like you
know what I don't have to explain to you
or to anybody else why I became a Muslim
yeah and God said that's what I was
trying to avoid I didn't feel like I had
to explain it to anybody you know
Gmail's a very good advice which from
you know someone whose name i'm i
promise not to mention but a prominent
musician who also became a muslim advise
me that the best thing I could do would
be to keep as quiet as possible you know
so I made a promise to myself that first
certainly at the time I would not go to
the mosque for example because I didn't
want media following me there yeah I'm
bringing all about there and also I made
a promise
I would only talk to you that when I was
ready to talk about it I would only talk
to you so I'm not after this I'm not
talking about it you know although
saying in saying that I know that can't
be true a because I'm female and I love
talking and I feel so passionately if I
heard Islam and and and passionately
about defending it against stigma that I
probably will talk a lot about it but I
wasn't ready you know well thank you so
much thank you for coming on the Dean
show is it you find it ironic that
people can make all different personal
decisions in life and they won't catch
as much heat they'll do all sorts of
things and now why when it comes to
Islam now it's like everybody's you know
yeah I'm sorry
well you know why it's because the very
tenant tenants of Islam are against
everything the world worships the world
worships money that Islam is the truth
and has the truth and has the truths
plural and that's why it's so dangerous
our culture is built on one great big
lie which is that Jesus Christ was the
son of God
right and all the ensuing lies that can
be manipulated out of that including the
very idea that Constantine had some type
of Epiphany sure he did he wanted to
exploit something and caused a whole
series Elias and that's what's happening
Islam as the truth the person who has
the truth and who also has nothing to
lose he's an extremely dangerous person
you know and that's how Islam is
perceived in in Ireland also we suffered
from the same stigma also because of
extremists that we also had extremists
because we had a war going on here and
there was a prejudiced and false idea
that if you stood up at all for Irish
nationalism this meant that you
supported terrorism you know and I think
that yours falsely it meant that you
know and I think that Islam suffered
from the same stigma that because there
are extremists and there are terrorists
it's very easy for those who want to
stigmatize us to say that we're all
terrorists and we all support terrorism
which of course we don't you know so and
then I found it what I was amazed by was
the prey
as I've found from women about the fact
that I choose to wear hijab because I
find it amusing because to me they're
saying to me that oh you're trying to
comply with Eastern men's view of beauty
first of all I'm not look at the saves
me I'm not beautiful at all and secondly
it's nothing to do it though it's a
choice and in fact under the under the
Islamic law might at my age I don't have
to wear a job actually yeah but what
amazes me about it is that these women
have their hair bleached blonde it's got
a thing going across here and it goes
down here their hair their hair itself
is a hijab they're very hair they're
trying to conform and [ __ ] to Western
men's idea of beauty so I keep saying
well if you don't like your job and
shave your hair it's the same thing
there's no difference to me so put on a
face that the prejudice about that I
find more prejudiced by wearing the
hijab than a but actually becoming
Muslim you know and I so consequently I
love wearing it you know I feel naked
people I mean you pretty much to sum it
up you said by saying the Shahada by
accepting Islam is that you love the
creator of the heavens and earth first
and foremost beyond materialism beyond
anything in creation you did what Jesus
did you did what Moses and all these
great messengers like Scot Almighty sent
that's all you're doing an essay you're
just choosing to love and put god
almighty first thing i'm not going to
lie about anything but the crater that's
a sling that's what Islam is what
happened to me was I had been studying
theology since I was 7 years of age
really in truth and I'd gone to college
and I had studied all different kind of
things and I had left Islam to last for
some reason probably because I have
prejudice you know and then what
happened was and only yesterday in the
Quran did I hear it being said that this
would happen to people who were happen
to me was as soon as I started to read
it and listened to it I realized oh my
god I've been a Muslim all my life and I
didn't know wow yeah I was a wall of my
life because it's a headspace it's a way
of thinking
Islam is a way of thinking about God
it's exactly what you just said somebody
who believes
in this world should be worshiped more
than God even though I fail sometimes
I'm not perfect I fail I worry about
money I worry about the teams that we
all worry about I forget sometimes that
I don't need to do that do you mean I
forgot look you know so yeah that's what
happened to me what if you say why did
you become why did you decide to revert
revert is the right word
yes I was always always yeah that's
that's that's the belief that every
child is born in a natural state if you
left it or own it would worship just the
Creator the one God alone yeah yeah and
that's what you did you came back to the
natural way you came back in a pure way
a pure monotheism worshipping yeah the
one God and it's very much for me about
the strength of the Scriptures the
intelligence the sheer intelligence of
the scriptures though I just knew
immediately like know about putting
wrote this for God nobody signed this to
Gabriel or tomorrow man but God nobody
could have created it but God it's so
intelligent so you know it's mind
blowing I can't even find words it's
mind blowing
I listen to that I'm more mind blown and
uh you know what I love as well which is
probably I shouldn't love what I do some
of the insults Irish people love insults
and I love when God gets annoyed and in
the Quran and Allah says things like we
will brown him upon the snide to know
things like that when God is in the
temporary it's kind of funny some of
these I love so much what he says and
you know if there were two gods in the
sky you would have ruined both of them
no no and that talks about the religion
that I laughed the religion was born
into which is Catholicism uh-huh you
know got to me summed up Catholicism do
it now now the the Irish people have a
really good history with the Muslims I
remember the potato famine
at one point when you had this potato
famine and then
Muslims came and you know lend support
and and the Irish have really been loyal
to that and they respected that that you
know that help and the Irish are really
amazing people we have are the second
largest minority if you like or majority
in this country is Islamic people is
Muslims so we have a huge Muslim culture
now you know but it's not big enough
because there's not enough mosques but
still the we are now done God we east
when I was growing up it was only
Catholicism here but in this country now
there are many different religions but
after Catholicism that the strongest and
most fastest growing religion in these
countries Islam is Islam er yes and so
the course the Coptic Church and
terrified the business on come on that I
mean it's no brainer and they've every
reason to be charged would you know the
whiskey this is always good enough for
Mohammed Ali it's good enough for me
it's good for anybody else you never say
but it good enough for Muhammad Ali it's
very frightening to cover the spirit
come anyways I can explain not for an
hour but yeah maybe you can because you
are you are the the person that Conor
McGregor picked out of everyone to come
out for his opening song maybe now you
can actually get help get some Dawa and
invite him to this to the purpose of
life you know maybe you can get him now
like he invited you you can invite him
for a sit down and talk to Conor
McGregor
yeah but you know what I really believe
is you know in the scripture where it
says you know take me by the forelock
and make Islam the limit of my desire
you know Allah will take who he wants Ya
Allah guides whom He wills yes cuz I see
I don't feel like it's my job to convert
anymore no that's none of our job is
just to be the best human beings we can
and to convey you know to try to do our
best to come here yeah I don't know
because I really do feel I love that
that part is scripted about this idea of
a lot ain't you by the forelock and
Brittany near to Islam if you know and
you won't you won't understand the crowd
or understand as I'm at all it isn't
already in you do you know I'm saying
nobody can put that in you yeah how was
it also we
when lindsay lohan do you know her when
she started reading the quran you know
she's trying to you know get her life
together and then as soon as the whiff
got around that she was reading the
cross she also caught some heat did you
ever talk to her me realize until after
I converted just that she had done the
same I saw an article about it so I
didn't wait I didn't realize she had
done that old but I was delighted to
know yeah I don't know her I never met
retina uh-huh
so you see you made it you made a
statement it's very powerful I'm proud
to have become Muslim the natural
conclusion of any intellectual so any
intellectual theologians journey I mean
that's such a profound statement I mean
this is not something that's hard to
figure out one God worship him alone
simple easy to understand and also you
know no theologians as far as I'm
concerned has the right to call
themselves a theologian if they have not
studied the Koran damn deeply listened
and I don't mean read it this is not for
reading that such she does alright to me
I don't get it when I just look at it
with my eyes I have to hear the way it
was designed to be heard you know then
but you can't say you're Talos
theologian if you haven't studied Islam
and if you study till up to Islam and
say you're a theologian and come out
trying to crucify Islam then you're not
a theologian either because you don't
have the intelligent only only up an
intelligent theologian could hear it
draaga I'm home
that's hot do you know yes you are how
is it now because you you you almost
like conquer the world I mean and what I
mean by that is that you had everything
that this world can offer right and many
people are still chasing that they feel
like if I just make a hit record if I
just make you know a little bit more
money you know how does it compare
because you've been all that and what
advice do you have for people who they
don't you know take it to the next level
they just you know sir come to their
desires and just want to chase material
the material things but they forget
about connecting with the one who
created them well you know I'm no
different
I'm the same as every other human being
we all do that we all
we're all flawed are no different as I
said to you earlier I worry about money
you know I'm not as rich as people might
think I am
you know this hurts or two years ago I
had one hit record you know I'm saying
to work to make my money same as anyone
else I'm not broke and I'm not a poverty
you know ii mean but ya know I'm worried
about the same things I forget sometimes
as I told you earlier to remember I
don't need to worry you know yeah yeah
so I don't feel like I'm in a position
to advise any person who is something
because you know I would advise people
often to hear the Quran unto the knees
no I'm talk to myself even what I say
this to believe that there's no reason
to assume that God has always taken care
of me so I have no reason to assume you
know that he won't continue to take care
of me but you know I suppose it's very
hard you can't from a position of
feeling okay lecture people who are not
okay it's a violation
you know Ernest oh yeah sometimes fate
doesn't put food in your mouth
you know that's Knox the fact is there
are an awful lot of people in the world
as we were talking we're dying of
starvation you can know they're the most
faithful people on earth yeah and I kind
of cause those people have a shitty liar
yeah how do you have some people come
around I mean now from the shock have
some friends or family like after
they've has anyone taken to initiative
to be like hold on let me open this
qur'an up let me actually see for myself
instead of hearsay and well the people
close to me were very good to me better
actually and the person who has become
interested is my father he is a very
religious person your father my father's
very religious person and he is very
interested in I have a hobby which is
painting scriptures I've always painted
scriptures and I made him recently the
scripture that says not a leaf falls but
he knows it Allah Masha Allah I gave
that to him for Father's Day and he
loved it and he said that he would like
to start to read the Koran but I keep
saying to people no don't readers listen
to us oh my god
it's not designed for reading my heart
couldn't read as it said
the prophet Isaiah right is predicted in
Isaiah saying he's going to be a
literacy kinda present that's actually a
prophecy prophesy and the last and final
mention of prophet muhammad yeah 29 29
yeah and so it's not so I keep saying to
me no please don't read it it's not for
reading this for listening to Muhammad
don't you think he must have been a
beautiful singer he must have a
beautiful voice you know to recite the
Quran to be the first person chosen by
God to recite the crime he must have had
its own voice just amazing goes beyond
comprehension that a man who was
illiterate he couldn't read or write
someone who was known as being Allah
mean the trustworthy to be able to
compile a book today that's memorized by
millions I mean all over the world and
and sometimes even if a person can't
understand what's being said but they
hear the Quran is powerful it's very
very private look if you look at how
that was creation it was designed for
the ear music I mean it's it's I know
that this is not PC to call it singing
because it is recitation but it's like
singing it's similar it's similar to
singing so music you see when when
something is to never that way it's the
only thing that doesn't go through your
intellect before it gets to your soul
because straight tear so see if you read
a thing is going through your intellect
you're thinking about it as you're
reading it you know where it's when you
listen to it you just carried away and
you've gone somewhere else immediately
to know that so what I love is on
YouTube they have these and this is what
I always tell people on YouTube they
have these beautiful recitations where
someone is reciting it in the Arabic and
then someone speaks the meaning of the
paragraph in English you know I've been
the one that I use is called charity
through the queen of Quran that's just
him speaking that's Jeremy - in Quran
but there's a beautiful playlist where
you can hear being recited and also
spoken yeah yeah it has to be listened
to so we'll leave that some advice from
Sinead O'Connor to listen to the Quran
to pick it up at least list
to it and and and why not ask the
Creator who created the heavens and
earth I'm sure like you did alone for
guidance if one is seeking person to
want to know purpose that's very
straightforward and simple yeah yeah
very very nice thank you so much Sinead
O'Connor what another thing is before we
cut out do you find that because of the
the Irish people were were also there
was at one point in time you know being
a minority they were also there was a
lot of some negative pressure do they
relate more with Muslims nowadays
knowing that you know Muslims are some
of the most oppressed people in the
world and some of this media hype that
Muslims are terrorists and all this
other you know hype that's this false
narrative that's being perpetuated they
can see through this yes absolutely
that's why people like me are reverting
that's exactly can see completely not
only through it you can see there of
course we can because of what's happened
in our own church the scandals that
everything that's been going on for the
last thirty years twenty years people
have been discovering the lies that
we've been discovering the Carlisle's
think the horrible smell of oppression
of the most vulnerable you know we've
been watching I just came from it and
you can inshallah God willing put it put
it on your to-do list to visit a hidden
gem I came from there and I'd like to
say that there's a deep history in
Bosnia and this is where my family's
from and when you study the history of
how the Bosnians came to Islam they were
actually crit Unitarian the true
Christians who didn't believe Jesus was
God or a literal son of God and they
also disconnected from the church and
they were considered heretics but they
were just once we just wanted a worship
like you like yourself they just wanted
to worship the one God and then when
Islam came submission to the will of God
Islam it fit like a glove they accepted
it and this is how Islam came to to
Bosnia that's know and this and this is
why we like to say that I make these are
points because many times people think
this is something of the other is
something far away but man we could say
well look we were the original
Christ followers the ones who follow
Christ in
your monotheism well that's exactly why
Islam is so dangerous
in inverted commas and to the work over
to the world it worships money because
as we said earlier on at the beginning
of this interview Islam is the truth
that has the truths you know that's very
very dangerous and then you have an
element to this on the field
understandably like it has nothing to
lose if your precedent will long enough
they're gonna feel like I got nothing to
lose and there's nothing more dangerous
than somebody armed with the truth who
also feels they've got nothing to lose
you know thank you so much may God
Almighty the creator Allah and Aramaic
the language Jesus spoke who we love and
reveal he would say aloha so that's the
same creator and he would say peace be
unto you
Shalom Oh lake we said I said out more
lake home you see we're bridging those
those gaps educating the people so they
can say like wow like you did wow that
makes sense I want to check that out
Thanks
yes thank you so much sister may Allah
continue to bless you and keep you
preserve you and keep you safe
thank you so much for being on the D
show and that was the legendary Sinead
O'Connor here on the D show we want to
thank you again
sister Sinead for sharing those key
points to our viewers in the world of
why you chose this beautiful way of life
that's practiced by close to 2 billion
human beings in the world it's the
fastest growing way of life in the world
which caused the human being to love
nobody else more than the Creator that
happens in the earth the one who Jesus
submitted to who Moses Abraham and the
last and final messenger prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon
them all they all called to Islam what
is Islam is that complete and total
submission and surrender to the creator
of the heavens and earth and that is how
you get richness contentment and peace
in the heart and that's how she what she
found in Islam so we invite you to do
what she advised you to do listen to the
Quran and then pick up the Quran and do
your best to try to connect with it the
owner of the body the human mind the
human heart revealed the blueprint for
life and all and the instruction manual
on how the human being is to live its
all there in the Koran and continue to
tune in here to the Dean shell every
week where we have a new and exciting
guest and we'll see you next time
subscribe if you haven't already and
leave us your takeaways in the comments
below and we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you
Salaam alaikum